oh my god why why i'm outnumbered again
oh we're gonna get cancelled by our own
fans
that song is so underrated
hi my name is buzzfeed to rank our songs
we have to eliminate one song at a time
whittle it down
it's going to be impossible we're going
to make it work
oh god oh this is already a very tough
start wasabi or touch
i mean why why they're both iconic
some of those two songs too wasabi is
iconic because it took on a life of its
own
but touch is of course touching site was
a game changer
was a game changer touch was the
turning point for little mix i think i
think when that came out
everyone's ears popped up it was like oh
that's a little mixture did you know
what i mean yeah yeah
and i think for touch as well it was
like one that my boyfriend
and all of the players would listen to
yeah in the changing rooms at football
like before a game and i'd be like wow
that's sick you know we're
cool yeah what it did for korea
it would have to be touch but um
delivered that wassabi's even in the
same rock
yeah wasabi's iconic
this is hard well they're all going to
be hot similar
they like both have a good message of
like female empowerment but for me
johnabot just tips over slightly really
yeah oh this one's hard for me but then
strip
character yeah video
we were going through some things at the
time we were feeling a little bit
picked apart by people by the press and
we got packed me and jade were like
upset about it
i think i would have to go straight
really yeah
i mean but it's hard because i love
jonah i feel like for the moment in time
and what it did
i'd probably have to say strip next no
more sad songs or black magic
oh i already know what no more sad songs
really sorry but i
that song is so underrated it's such a
crowd favorite i love that song
so much love yeah super underrated yeah
as well yeah connie and we love that
magic we do
but the video is everything well at
least that was an easy one
okay next up shout out to my ex or comfy
they're completely shout out to my ex
could be with any song
and it would always win yes it would it
just would
it's a [ __ ] for confetti because
confetti is such a good song but
you're right anything up against that
song is going to be
crushed so the winner is shout out to
maya yeah well that was easy
next woman's world or no time for tears
again they're like completely different
songs so it's hard to i'm trying to
think of moments though do i mean like
if the song represents the moment i'd
see a woman's face
a nice ballad to sing but i think salute
because it's just
empowering it's very different as well i
know like
you think it was not a song like salute
yeah i mean and it's such a big
song to perform live as well so we could
open any like festival with salute
because people love to hear it next up
is wings
and i love you oh hello guys
i love you it's my favorite little mix
song i don't know but wings is such
it was the thing that started us off and
catapulted us into stars again no
this is our creation i'm gonna lose this
one i know
we might have to lose i know wings will
never die
and when i think of wings i think foxes
babies like i think
we were so young when we wrote that song
with ian ian james
and the tms boys and i don't think we
knew for one second
how successful and how big the song
would be at the time because we were
just so naive and so excited yeah
life and being in the industry so wings
wins
next up for me it's just like no brainer
oh it's some normal bracelets sweet
melody or free freak
sweet melody sweet melody
is it is that like female did not come
to play it so while he turned up was
like
do do do do steal a thunder
and when we do this live it's going to
go off oh wait no it actually it's
actually going to go
off we've obviously performed it on tvs
and stuff but doing that live
on tour or with our fans with the crowd
yeah
i can't literally it's going to be here
okay right now we're on the other side
secret love song part two
or love me or leave me oh wow this is
hard oh
this is really hard i feel like the fans
will never forget myself
don't give love with me or leave me a
chance
it never got the love and appreciation
it deserved we never got to come back
we never released it as a single we
never did anything with it and it's such
a beauty i think we were scared to sing
it because it's so hot
i mean try belting out that middle ear
every night
no but i think it would be a nice one to
sing i think like i love you
me trying to sing that life i would
probably die like rip to me
love me or leave me because it's
emotional and it's vulnerable
yeah the emotion behind it you can be
all sensitive with it and
it's like real we have to go super
awesome because we did on this we kind
of
went with the success of what we've had
in the like moments we had around the
song with
the secret love song all right next up
lightning a little me
oh wow lightning's sick song
i listened to lightning a week ago or
something randomly
and i just sat there and i thought what
a masterpiece no it's crazy the opera
yeah is it like what did we sing
literally everything was just like so
extra but then little me
guys little me just speaks to so many
people
this is what a beautiful mess is so
beautiful what we brought to our younger
selves
what we brought to our younger fans to
like inspire them but then i think as
like a masterpiece of a song
i would say lightning
in the nicest way i know what you mean
there's something about that song just
really
just like a little you know the end of
the hauntingly
with a voice is just very haunting oh
guys i'm sorry good enough is such a
beautiful one
it is it really is but i think i agree
with jade i think monster in the
afternoon
[Music]
i don't know why okay
it's weird because good enough to me
it's like wow vocals beautiful stripped
back valid
but monster on me when i listen to it it
gives me a tingle okay next
motivate or holiday i would say holiday
holiday all day
you two love holidays
but i always love motivation i remember
writing
the studio and just being like really
hot under the collar
we were drunk with tipsy jig barely
remembers it because she dressed up
again it was so much fun and it's just
like i remember everyone was just
showing and they're like
yeah we're all dancing that was really
fun but
i'm gonna say holiday guess what i'm
outnumbered again
oh no woman like me or breakup song
breakup song oh
sorry right because breakup song is
another one of my favorite
songs yeah you do yes and you love it i
love it woman like me
was successful yeah did very well
but we weren't 100 on it at the time
listen yeah don't underrate bounce back
like that okay
now i'll do it don't make me laugh no
okay it's not a question but bounce back
is yeah bounce back is
bounce back it's a little bit of a bob
sure but it's how
we're coming out now is like tough
it's aggressive it's strong yeah it's
empowering
the music video was sick and the man's
are in the video yeah
the video we shot in l.a it was an
amazing experience
okay how are you the cure or these
walls these four walls guys
we wrote that literally just us guys
girls in a room yeah and we recorded it
on a handheld mic
yeah like it was very intimate and very
raw very super special
the cure is so beautiful
i would personally go with move because
i feel like when we brought that out
nothing else sounded like move
yeah it was a brave single choice that
we believed in and run with
and i think it's another underwater book
to be honest yeah in terms of what i
would listen to it would be the class
because i love that song yeah i would
listen to think about us more
but then i'm thinking of it from a
buyer's point of view so i'm thinking of
singing it and i enjoy seeing a thing
about us
when i sing move can i find the pitch no
basically never can i no i'm always a
bit flat or shocked
that move i guess was like a moment
pivotal do you know what it is for me
it's the move
it's the move baseline yeah
[Music]
so i think just for that baseline alone
i'm gonna have to say
all right okay next round so touch your
strip
touch easy no more sad songs are shout
out to my
air shout out to my shout out bye no
more sad songs
women's world are salutes wings of sweet
melody
sweetie wait
yeah it kind of has to be and then these
four walls are moved
move yes all right yeah all right next
round
touch or shout out to my eggs no why
don't you
do that because they're our biggest ones
they are literally
the two iconic oh i'm going to say touch
i know i said that shout out always win
but
i'm listening i'm gonna have to say
shout out
i'm just going off if i'm in a club and
one of the songs comes on which one am i
immediately gonna
hit the dance floor and give you a
quarry and give you what you want i get
that
but we could travel anywhere in the
world when you're here this is
uh to my face and you hear the whole
crowd walk so i think it's time
because everyone's just like yes like
how badass do we feel when we said
in touch yes it is streamed more
well we've got more video views on touch
more video views
yeah that's our most important video
touch because yeah
because people love the titty bounce
yeah
i think okay if i'm outnumbered i'm
happy with these no babe
i can't believe i don't know i'm gonna
choose one two three touch one two three
oh no send out a preference and it will
be touched preference okay
touch then all right it's fine it is
what it is you know well we're gonna get
cancelled by our own fans
no they're gonna they'll understand how
all right salute our sweet melody
sweetness all right that was easy enough
all right next secret love song on
holiday
secret love song secret love song power
remove power
okay we're up to the final four touch or
sweet melody
oh sweet melody's like chuch's older
sister
no it is i'd say sweet melody's the
sibling
is horrible what oh
people saying i wish we could write
something like touch right that's how
good it was
but sweet melody was a cultural research
the fact that it was around like 10
weeks then all of a sudden was like hi
guys by the way i'm number one
yeah number one no but it should have
sounded
it definitely deserves oh i'll let you
have to watch it
okay it has to be i'm happy okay secret
love song of power
that's hard oh you're stunned i think
i'd say secret awesome
i think i would say secret love song
okay final two
touch or secret love song i can't
believe shout out's not in there but
okay i'm like it's because
[Laughter]
so there you have it after whittling
every single thing down
oh my favorite little song is touch i'm
okay with that i was okay with that or
shout out
i'm happy we wanna know what you guys
think what you wheeled it down to and
what your favorite little mix song was
so yeah leave all your comments and
we can't wait to read through them we
love you guys so much
lots bye